So numbers chapter 20 shows us that it had,
it had been 40 years
since the dramatic incident at Adeem where God ordered Moses
to strike the rock, providing water
for the parched Israelites.
And yet here again, Moses faced a thirsty people.
Bitter accusations were hurled at Moses, things like,
if only we had died when our brothers fell
dead before the Lord.
Why did you bring the Lord's people into the desert that we
and our livestocks should die here?
Distraught. Moses and Aaron fell on their faces before God.
And God gave them these instructions.
He said, gather the people together, speak to that rock
and it will pour out its water.
So Moses gathered all the people,
called them out in anger, and then he raised his arm
and he struck the rock twice with his staff
and water gushed out.
And the people in their livestock drank
another stunning miracle.
God had done this, that that clear artesian water
flowed out of a rock.
And every one of the million plus people in their
animals drank their fill.
What a huge success, right?
I mean, you can imagine Moses and Aaron high fiving
and hugging and, and no doubt embracing one another
with this reality of,
of a thunderous roar rolling across the wilderness
as the people celebrated.
Moses was again, a hero.
Through him, God had met the needs of his people.
Israel was miraculously preserved
and they gave glory to where it belonged to God.
It seemed to be another resounding success in Moses' life.
But that was Earth's point of view.
From Heaven's perspective, Moses had sadly failed.
See, in his fury, Moses had disregarded God's direction
to speak to the rock,
and instead had taken his staff and struck it twice.
And his tragic failure was of such proportion
that he would not fulfill his life's cherished dream
of leading Israel into the Promised land.
God said to him this,
because you did not trust in me enough to honor me
as holy in the sight of the Israelites.
You will not bring this community into the
land that I've given them.
What a sad ending to a great story.
But what does that have to do with us today?
Like what in the world does that matter for us?
Well, Kent Hughes said it this way.
It means that one can be regarded
as hugely successful in ministry and yet be a failure.
It's possible to give people exactly what they need,
the practical exposition of God's word.
Inspiring worship programs that meet the needs
of people wonderfully and yet still be a failure.
It's possibly be held up as a model of success
and receive the passionate accolades of one's people
and yet be a failure.
The reason Moses so miserably failed was
that he was not faithful to God's word.
It's what one Corinthians four, two says.
It is required of stewards that they be found faithful.
See, that's the heart of what God's word's gonna teach us
today, both primarily
for leaders in the church,
but I believe this is applicable to every one of us
as we go through our lives.
And so turn there with me now to one Corinthians.
Chapter four will be verses one through five.
Today, one Corinthians four, one through five.
Similar to last week, Paul was referring to his
and other main leader's position.
Yet he was applying it beyond him
to other church leaders that would follow him.
He was saying, here's the way he should see
and the way we should see ourselves.
One Corinthians four verses
one through five, let me read it.
This is how one should regard us as servants of Christ
and stewards of the mysteries of God.
Moreover, it's required of stewards
that they be found faithful.
But with me it is a very small thing that I should be judged
by you or by any human court.
In fact, I do not even judge myself for I'm not aware
of anything against myself, but I am not thereby acquitted.
It is the Lord who judges me.
Therefore, do not pronounce judgment before the time
before the Lord comes who will bring
to light the things now hidden in darkness
and will disclose the purposes of the heart.
Then each one will receive his commendation from God.
Lord, this is your word.
We're thankful that you gave it to us
And You've given it to us today for a reason.
And God, I pray you give us hearts to receive,
to be good soil for this word to plant in us,
to bear good fruit in our lives.
That we would be doers of the word, not hearers only,
and that we would have ears to hear
what you have to say to us today.
Humble us, God, before your mighty hand.
Lead us to repentance as we need it
and lead us in the way of our lasting today.
God, for your glory. In Jesus' name.
Amen. And so again,
Paul was primarily talking about church leaders here.
And that's the angle that he's saying.
And we're gonna take a primary angle there,
but remember that in a way we're all leading someone in some
way, whether that's at work
or at home, maybe CG leaders,
elders within the church, authors that you're reading,
blog writers, social media, influencers.
Like there's a measure of of watching
and seeing how we should see them as well as
how they should see themselves.
And so throughout today, consider also how this applies
to every one of us in some form as we go,
but primarily it is to church leaders.
So first, here's the question,
what's a leader's correct posture?
What is a leader's correct posture?
Well, a chiropractor says upright,
shoulders back, kind of head.
Wait, no, not that posture.
Okay, although that is good,
but not what we're talking about here today.
How they see themselves, how others
see them as well.
That's this posture. And verse one is very clear.
He says, leaders should have the posture of servants.
Leader should have the posture of servants.
This is how someone should regard us,
how someone should think about us.
It's as servants of Christ, the Messiah.
Now, this actually is not the typical word for servant.
He uses in other writings, other places.
He uses the word that we get deacon from
and that's how he uses the word servant.
But, but here he's using a word for like a helper
or a, a task runner.
It's really a no name who is an assistant
to someone in an official position.
I was a page at the state capitol in high school.
Like nobody knew. It didn't, it didn't matter who I was.
It was that I have a task and you go do this
because you're serving someone in an official capacity.
That means in this word the way he uses it, there's a,
an a humility inherent to the position.
There's something that you, you,
you're just simply following orders, just doing your job.
You're a servant in that way,
which dovetails nicely with the second posture.
He says that of stewards of the message, servants
of the Christ, stewards of the message.
Now we don't use the word steward very often in our day,
but a steward was a household servant, often a slave,
yet was given a measure
of authority over the other household servants.
They're often referred to as overseers.
That's why we know Paul was primarily referring
to church leaders here
because that's one of his favorite designations
for pastors and elders.
In fact, in Titus one seven, he calls overseers
of the church stewards.
So this is the idea he's getting to here.
There's a stewardship in leadership, but stewards of what?
Stewardship of what is he talking about here?
He says the mysteries of God.
Now, does that mean we'll never know anything about
God because it's all mysterious?
No. What he's I I rephrased it to say the message.
What message? The message about God.
Back then it was the apostles who were called
to steward the testimony of Christ's life, death,
and resurrection to ensure that it was, it was going out
accurately to the world as it spread.
They were the ones who were checking
and making sure that it was right.
But after them, as the, the scriptures were written,
as things began to grow,
it was then the whole council of God.
It was all the mysteries of the kingdom
that God was revealing through his word
that church leaders, apostles and beyond are to steward
and preserve all of that in a way,
yet also employ it for multiplication.
'cause that's what a steward does, right?
A steward was given authority in a way over the
master's resources.
By the way, remember it's not the steward's resources.
You don't own anything. It's the master's resources.
The steward is to use for the benefit of the master
and the benefit of the rest of the household.
They were to invest and serve
and work so that the, the household flourished
through the use of the resources.
Do you see the dignity in that? Right?
So we think slave stu servant in this context steward,
it's a lesser position.
There's a dignity to this.
When Paul says we are stewards of the mysteries,
there's a massive level of dignity.
So when you apply this to church leaders, then
the servant of Christ, steward of the gospel, the message
it brings with it an appropriate level
of authority within the church,
but at the same time an appropriate level
of humility of service.
Say I'm here for you household, right?
Uh, as a steward, they would be there
for the benefit of everyone else.
That's what a steward does.
All that though brings up the next question.
What is the leader's correct goal?
That's the correct posture, both the way yours
to see leaders and the way leaders are to see themselves.
But what's the goal for a leader?
Well look at verse two again.
He says, it is required of stewards, not optional.
This isn't something that you can choose to do or not.
It is required of stewards that they be found faithful.
Now as we go into this, this section here,
this will actually push on the modern church
us a little bit.
It's gonna step on our toes a little bit.
Because the reality is that even though we might say
otherwise, the prevailing measure in
our day of when a church is doing well
or when a church is struggling is based on numbers.
The prevailing measurement in our current modern church
culture of success is numbers.
Now we may nuance that a little bit here and there.
We try to make it seem like that's not true.
What we're really basing it on is, but,
but let me just tell you my own heart.
I know, I know where I have been and am at times
and I can so easily fall into the trap
that when attendance is up, budget's up,
whatever trends up, man,
I can start feeling pretty good about myself.
I can start feeling pretty good about the church,
but when the numbers are lower, I can
so easily feel like a failure.
That's why all the way back in 1987, Kent
and Barbara Hughes wrote a great book called Liberating
Ministry from the Success Syndrome.
I had it on my shelf literally for probably 15 years.
And just in the last few months,
God brought it back to mind.
And it is powerful
because in it, Kent, who was a pastor for 40 some years,
he especially wrestles with this pressure.
He felt as a pastor that if things were not growing
it was his fault and he was a failure.
He felt like he wasn't successful,
he wasn't succeeding in the ministry.
But is that true? No.
And Paul's very clear here in chapter four
that the goal of a leader is not success.
Like success is not the goal. Paul says.
Now, we'll talk about later. Who judges that anyway?
We'll, we'll see that, but,
but quote unquote, success cannot be what we shoot for.
That can't be our main measure of worth in ministry
or in life at all.
Now, the thing that's required of stewards, the thing
that our master desires is faithfulness.
Like even high school seniors, as you guys go out to
the next phase of life,
the whole world tells you be successful.
Okay, well I think in a right frame we can keep that, but,
but this is the main point.
To be faithful.
That's the gold. The word faithful means true,
trustworthy, reliable.
Are you faithful?
It doesn't matter how much you have or what place you have
or position you have.
Are you faithful with what God has entrusted to you?
That's why I love the parable of the talents
that Jesus gave in Matthew 25.
Just listen to how this goes.
Paint the picture in your head as I read it.
Jesus says, it will be like a man going on a journey
who called his servants, the bond servants, maybe stewards
and entrusted to them his property to one,
he gave five talents.
That's a measure of money. Five talents to another.
He gave two to another.
He gave one to each according to his ability.
And then he went away. He
who had received the five talents went at
once and traded with them.
And he made five talents more.
So also, he who had the two talents made two talents more.
But he who had received the one talent went
and dug in the ground and hid his master's money.
Now, after a long time, the master of those servants came
and settled accounts with them.
And he who had received the five talents came
forward bringing five talents.
More saying, master, you delivered
to me five talents here I made five talents more.
And his master said to him, well done, good
and faithful servant.
You've been faithful over a little.
I will set you over much. Enter into the joy of your master.
And he also who had the two talents came forward saying,
master, you delivered me two talents here.
I made two talents more.
His master said to him, well done,
good and faithful servant.
You've been faithful over a little.
I'll set you over much enter into the joy of your master.
But he also who had received the one talent came forward
saying, master, I knew you to be a hard man reaping
where you did not sow gathering where you scattered no seed.
So I was afraid and I went
and hid your talent in the ground.
Here you have what is yours?
Meaning he gave him the one talent back,
but his master answered him you wicked and slothful servant.
You knew that I reap where I have not sown you gather
where I scattered no seed.
Then you ought to have invested my money with the bankers.
And at my coming, I should have received
what was my own with interest.
And his end is not pretty.
But I want us to notice a few things about this parable.
First, the master wanted the stewards to do something with
what he'd given them, right?
He entrusted them to do something with it.
But also notice it didn't matter
how much they had been given
or that the amount produced on the back end was equal
amongst the three.
'cause notice the servant who'd been given five,
he handed back 10.
So the masters got 10.
But then the servant who had been given
two handed the master.
Four. Now, okay, a hundred percent, we love that.
But but notice the, the end result, the harvest,
you might say was different,
but what was the master's response to both
exactly the same, right?
He says, well done, good and faithful servant.
You have been faithful over a little.
I will set you over much enter into the joy of your master.
Now, I've always wondered, what about the one,
what about the guy who had the one?
Well, I believe we can safely assume that if that man
or woman, whoever it was,
would have taken the one talent gone
and done the same thing that the other two had done
and invested it and brought back two to the master,
what do you think he would've heard?
Well done. Good and faithful servant.
Been faithful over a little.
You've said over much enter the joy, right? The same thing.
It didn't matter what they had started with
or what they even amount brought back,
it was they were faithful, right?
And Chris Austin said this faithfulness in little things
is a big thing.
And so again, the point here is that the goal of ministry,
the goal of life is not success.
It's not more, it's not bigger.
The goal is faithfulness.
And the context of Matthew 25 is in the Jesus dialogue
of saying about the end times.
He's saying that masters coming back pretty soon.
How are you going to handle what he's given you now
until he comes that master's returning soon?
Are we faithful?
Okay, great. We would all agree.
We need to be faithful according to what standard though,
according to what standard, who's the judge
of whether we are faithful or not?
Because that's the question we have is, is all right.
Faithfulness is what we look for. But who's the judge?
And I've, I've already heard it this morning once I,
I think we inherently know the answer.
This kids, this was your Sunday school answer.
Who's the judge of this? Jesus? Yeah, we got that right.
Okay, we got that. We know that inherently.
But the interesting part of one Corinthians four,
hope you notice this, is that it,
it offers us some alternatives
that I know I slip into at times.
Like when the enemy tosses into my heart this question
of whether I'm being faithful or not.
And that scale begins to go back and forth.
And I'm wondering and questioning whether I'm faithful
or not, I can slip into these other alternatives
that Paul offers here.
The first one is in the first part of verse three here,
first Corinthians four, verse three.
Just the very first part he says,
but with me, it is a very small thing
that I should be judged by you or by any human court.
And so the question he's asking here is whether others are
an appropriate judge of faithfulness or not?
Are others an appropriate level of faithful judge or not?
Are the judgments of others sufficient
to say whether someone is faithful or not?
Because here's what was happening back then.
Here's the context of what he's talking about.
There were some were saying in Corinth, some were saying,
Hey, Paul's better at this.
Apollos is better at this, or he's worse at this,
or he's being faithful here.
He's wrong in this.
And they were, they were judging all of these leaders
and preachers and people that they had been listening to
and on and on it goes that they were beginning to separate
and divide over those things.
Even judging Paul by their worldly standard in Corinth,
which he actually talked about in chapter one, that he said,
I did not come to Corinth with your spirit of debate
and wisdom because I didn't, I I didn't want to.
Knowing that you would trust that instead
of trusting Christ in him crucified.
So he knew he wasn't being judged
accurately 'cause they were judging on that.
And so here he says, I'm not worried about
what people think about me.
I'm not worried about whether I measure up
to some worldly standard or not.
In fact, if you would ask Paul, he says this in other parts
of the scriptures, if you'd ask him, he'd be like, actually,
I'm far worse than you think I am.
You've said all this, boy, you didn't even get all of it.
So other people cannot be an accurate judge of
what faithfulness is.
Now we need to listen to what other people say.
Of course we do, because they might be right.
They might be seeing something in my life that I'm blind to,
so don't completely shut it off.
But, but just because a bunch of people say something is
faithful or
because a bunch of people say something isn't faithful.
Doesn't mean it necessarily is true either way.
But here's what can happen as a result.
And I know this is true because I've done this.
We work so hard to shut off the noise from others.
I don't care what you say, I'm not gonna listen to it.
And we just stay in our own head.
And what we end up doing is we become our own judge.
No one else judges but me.
But is that the right way to measure faithfulness?
Either because look at
how Paul continued here in verse three.
He says, in fact, I do not even judge myself.
Meaning I don't even sit back
and say, well, all those people are wrong
because I know what's really true about me.
Right? They, you kinda shut everything off in a bubble.
You just say, I'm not gonna listen to any of you.
'cause I know what's true about myself
and I have this bubble around me.
Here's the problem. We can
so quickly deceive ourselves, can't we?
Anyone else ever been in denial of a problem
in your own life, right?
You just kind of like you're addicted to something.
You're like, well, that's not that bad.
It's not really that big of a problem.
I can overcome any, right? Anybody else? Maybe just me.
I saw two hands. Okay, great. Um,
Listen, it can even happen for those of us in ministry
where anyone on the other side of an issue
or anyone who's critiquing
is just automatically wrong.
And that's not right. That's not a good attitude
because we tend to overestimate our own faithfulness.
We tend to judge highly ourselves
and judge harshly other people.
But look at what Paul says in verse four.
He says, yeah, I don't even judge myself for, I'm not aware
of anything against myself.
Meaning as far as I can tell, I haven't done anything.
But I am not thereby acquitted.
It is the Lord who judges me.
But, but notice he said that I'm not aware,
but I'm not acquitted
because there might be something in me
that I didn't even know I was doing at the time or,
or there's something deep inside me that,
that I assumed my motives were pure in doing this.
But it really wasn't. Paul's
basically saying, I know I'm not perfect.
How does he know that? Because like I read the last phrase,
it is the Lord who judges me.
See, Paul knew there was still something in him
because his true standard of faithfulness was a holy God.
We can't always trust other people's judgments.
We can't even trust our own judgments
because we might self deceive.
That's why our true standard of faithfulness must be God.
The right standard is the judge.
Nothing, no one.
The right standard is, is him
for, I'm not aware of anything against myself,
but I am not thereby acquitted.
It is the Lord who judges me.
Therefore do not pronounce judgment before the time
before the Lord comes who will bring
to light the things now hidden in darkness
and will disclose the purposes of the heart.
Each one will receive his commendation from God.
May we see this exposure happen almost every day,
even in our time.
Don't we, a pastor
or a church might look like a success,
but it all crumbles when the unfaithfulness that's been
behind the curtain finally gets exposed
and it's so destructive to a church.
It's so destructive to the kingdom.
That's why a, a primary goal must be faithfulness
to God first.
Like we can't focus on numbers or growth
or influence at the expense
of seeking holiness before God.
That's got to be primary.
That's why nearly all the qualifications
of a church leader in scripture are character based.
It's not skill-based.
You have to be able to handle the word, but it's character
because faithfulness matters first.
But here's the reality. Yes, things happen.
We see it exposed around us almost every week it seems.
But the reality is that not everything will get exposed
before Jesus returns.
Yes, we have an obligation
to call one another toward faithfulness here
and now God's spirit's gonna use his word
to convict us, to change us.
That's part of the deal.
But in the end, the only thing you can take responsibility
for is yourself.
Are you being faithful to God? Am I being faithful to God?
Am I seeking to know and obey his word?
Am I leaning on his faithfulness for me, his life, death
and resurrection for me when I fail?
Like, do I remember that Keller said this?
Do I remember that? I am more sinful than I could ever
imagine, yet I am more loved than I could ever dare hope.
Like is that where I'm at?
And I just see, yes, I wanna be faithful God,
I'm not gonna be, but thank you for grace
and I pursue you in that.
Is that where I'm at? Those are great questions to ask
as God exposes our hearts in light
of the future, light of his return.
Like yes, we need to all, all the time, self examine God,
show me Psalm 1 39.
Is there any wicked way within me?
But here's what happens with a passage like this.
We so often make it only negative.
Like we get this picture of, of some scary old man, like,
God's gonna judge you, be a good boy, right?
Like that's kinda what it feels like at times. Scary.
But what are the last few words of verse five?
Did you see it? God brings things to light,
discloses motivations.
Look at the end of verse five.
Then each one will receive his commendation from God.
See, that's why we can't judge perfectly accurately
before the Lord comes,
because first, he's the only one who can.
He's the only one who can see our hearts.
But also because what we may think is success
may actually be motivated by sinful desires, by pride,
by wrong perspectives, all of that.
So we can't just say it's because it's great,
but also what we might deem a failure.
Again, church culture, a small church or
or someone who doesn't have all the notoriety
that certain people have,
or no one ever sees anything that
that person does when hidden things are exposed,
God blesses faithfulness.
Even when it's quiet, even when it is hidden.
That's what's praised by God. Think about it.
There are so many faithful things done
that no one else ever sees.
It's not just because people can perform or
or can produce or have large followings.
It's so much.
No one else sees a cup of water to someone who is thirsty,
comforting a child, caring for a sick spouse
for years in the quiet places,
turning from pornography, sitting
with the abused, praying diligently for others,
writing an encouragement note to someone,
sitting next to someone on a plane, sharing the gospel,
studying scripture devoted, tearful over it
and on and on and on.
We could go. It doesn't make a global impact,
but God sees it and
he rewards those who are faithfully building
with the good stones of faithful life.
That's why Paul, even though he was being criticized,
doubted, even at times abandoned.
That's why he could carry on
and wait for the eternal praise from God
because it wasn't a clean conscience
or his effort that brought that praise.
It was the gospel truth of Jesus and him crucified for him.
It's the same for us. Listen, if God chooses
to bring fruit from our faithfulness, great, we'd love that.
But if he doesn't, that's not why we're seeking
to be faithful anyway just for fruit.
No, it's because of Second Corinthians five,
verse nine says, whether we are at home
or away, we make it our aim to please him.
Meaning if it's an audience of one, it's no one else.
We serve a faithful God.
A God that is so faithful that he makes us faithful
through Jesus Christ in our place.
And he gives us faithfulness as a fruit
of his spirit inside of us.
So lean into that rest in that
as we seek to be faithful to our faithful God.
Let's ask him for help towards that now.